TRUMP AND RUSSIA COLLUSION.
>> GONE.
>> Sean: NEVER HAPPENED.
>> HE'S BEEN CLEARED.
>> Sean: MY QUESTION IS, ARE
YOU CONCERNED, AND THE PROCESS
THIS, WE DID DISCOVER THAT A
FOREIGN NATIONAL, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, WAS PAID THROUGHSI
FUSION GPS, USED RUSSIAN SOURCES
THAT NOT ONLY WANT VERIFIED,
WERE DEBUNKED, ARE YOU CONCERNED
THAT THAT WAS PAID FOR TO
MANIPULATE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IN THE LEAD UP TO AN ELECTION?
>> ISN'T THAT CLOSER TO THE
MANDATE THAT MICHAEL COHEN?
>> Sean: WHERE MUELLER ON
THAT, SIR?
>> HAVING SOMETHING TO DO WITH
PAYING SOME STORMY DANIELS WOMAN
130,000?
I MEAN, IT'S GOING TO TURN OUT
TO BE PERFECTLY LEGAL.
THAT MONEY WAS NOT CAMPAIGN
MONEY.
SORRY, I'M GIVING YOU A FACT NOW
YOU DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT CAMPAIGN MONEY.
NO CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
>> Sean: THEY FUNNELED IT
THROUGH A LAW FIRM.
>> FUNNELED OUT THROUGH A LAW
FIRM AND THE PRESIDENT REPEATED.
>> Sean: OH, I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT HE DID.
THERE IS NO CAMPAIGN FINANCE
LAW.
>> ZERO.
JUST LIKE EVERY -- SEAN --
>> Sean: MR. DECISION WAS MADE
BY --
>> EVERYONE WAS NERVOUS ABOUT N
IT.
I WASN'T.
I KNEW HOW MUCH MONEY
DONALD TRUMP AT INTO THAT
CAMPAIGN, 130,000 -- A COUPLE OF
CHECKS FOR 130,000.
WHEN I HEARD COHEN'S RETAINER OF
35,000 WHEN HE WAS DOING NO WORK
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
I SAID, THAT IS HOW HE IS
REPAYING -- HE IS REPAYING IT,
WITH A LITTLE PROFIT AND A
LITTLE MARGIN FOR PAYING TAXES.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THI
THIS?
I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT --
>> HE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS OF IT AS FAR AS I KNOW
BUT HE DID KNOW ABOUT THE
GENERAL ARRANGEMENT THAT MICHAEL
WOULD TAKE CARE OF THINGS LIKE
THIS.
LIKE I TAKE CARE OF THINGS LIKE
THIS FOR MY CLIENTS.
I T DON'T BURDEN THEM WITH EVERY